we're gonna watch the official trailer
for the witches today reject nation
excited check this out robert zemeckis
game of the toro co-wrote it
let's get into it are we just not gonna
talk about the thing on your head
this it's called the shirt john don't
make a big deal out of it
sure dumb ass okay here's the thing i
have curly hair right
and then i saw a tick tock video not
long ago that said that the best way to
dry
curly hair put some little conditioner
in it and then put
wrap it in a shirt because something
something fabric something something
something docks
on something is complete they said you
should have it dry for about 45 minutes
to an hour
but uh by the time we're done watching
this trailer it'll probably be about 25
minutes i'll still see what it looks
like after
i'll do an unveiling of my curve
i am excited for that in a curling video
that is chris rock i didn't know he was
involved in this
[Music]
[Music]
demonetized over five seconds
welcome what a great color
he would palette source brass so the
animals are cgi now
uh i guess rats
we will exterminate the rats
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't matter who you are what you look
like
as long as somebody loves you oh i
wouldn't happen to be carrying around
a mouse on your person now would you a
mouse
why on earth would i be carrying around
the maps
[Music]
bring the big street home ah that's a
good this was supposed to be a theater
release originally was it i believe so
i believe robert zemeckis is still
theater material
all right before we talk about this oh
are we doing this
yeah it's really stiffening my body
language
i can't i can't i can't i don't know how
to undo the knot oh my god
oh no you got it you're good you're
great you're so good baby so your money
baby your money vegas baby vegas
oh look at that look at that oh
this is a sexy look right there now i
gotta comb my hair and
now you gotta start like uh like a and
this is just
crunch it and you gotta start a
character scrunch it
then yeah scrunching yeah that's a good
haircut look curly
it looks yeah i mean it looks wavy and
nice you know it looks uh you should
shoot like a really intense like you
know rain fight or something right now
and get the full advantage of like oh
it's dripping out of every fiber
i just think you gotta mix up the
commentary you know you gotta mix up
you get so routine with the channel you
gotta you gotta do different things once
in a while yeah yeah and this relates to
the witches because they don't have hair
but look at all this hair that you have
you know so like you know they might
wanna steal your hair and make it one of
their wigs or something
because of how beautiful your locks are
so let's talk about the witches
[ __ ] yeah oh god this is really
annoying the whole rest of the video is
you figuring out how to operate
i like the trailer i thought it was very
charming and cute and what
what i really like about it that it has
kind of that
throwback vibe of uh the kind of
halloween
movies for families that you just don't
really get anymore it feels
like extremely family-friendly as it
should
and to some i feel like some might have
a bit of an argument with that i think
most people's familiarity would be
with the 1990 movie a movie that um
is terrifying it's scary like
jim henson's i don't know if jim henson
did the makeup but i know his team at
least worked on it right i believe it is
feel free to correct me i believe it is
the last movie that he himself
okay worked on okay all right all right
thanks for clarifying thank you john
any old time buddy oh oh john just has
to steal the thunder no no no everyone
knows your hair's ready
i'll tie a braid do a rest of this video
try to make you look less than on camera
do i guys even in a joking manner
yeah though family halloween quality
while the book is obviously popular i
think a lot of us will probably
associate
the story of the witches with the 1990
movie
you know um because let's face it we're
millennials and the nintendo movie came
out in
1990 that's right at the break when we
all stopped reading books
yep it's all tv
looking at the trailer here i like the
performances i think octavia spencer was
probably the highlight to me and
hathaway has a big task ahead of herself
there seems to be this thing with her
where people just there's just like this
weird group
online doubting him don't like anne
hathaway yeah
and i've always liked that hathaway but
there's these people who just get like
triggered by anne hathaway for some
reason angelica houston was
essentially the biggest presence of the
last movie she will
undoubtedly be compared to her and uh
stanley tucci looks great it's a double
worse proper reunion the thing though is
you know just just knowing especially
with
henson working on this might not matter
to most people
i imagine it won't but with henson's
team working on the 1990 witches movie
the fact that
they've cgi'd a lot that was kind of
like disturbing makeup before
yeah imagine can be a bit disappointing
for something yeah i mean especially if
you are old enough to remember that
movie and that's one of those things
where you're going to be torn among the
whole you know well the kids this is
probably partly and toward now aren't
going to notice or care and then yeah
you're going to have the adults who
will be upset but i don't know i mean
because it's robert semekis i'm very
curious because again he is
he knocks it out of the park all 99 of
them
most of the time especially when working
in
physical hit or miss affects heavy areas
that's that's the thing though is
because you know he has become so known
in the recent years for these very
effects heavy or completely effects
driven movies and so
partly i feel like scaling that back to
just maybe the witch and mouse effects
could be neat i mean like having seen it
practically before
and knowing how tangible the story is
and how you know at least what it calls
for could be achieved pretty tangibly
pretty i
think succinctly through physical
effects i wouldn't begrudge it i'd have
to see more because what they're showing
me here i mean it definitely looks like
the witches i'm not
upset about reframing it in the 60s
america
versus you know the 80s in in britain
because like the original movie
this is one of the rare forms of media
that i've consumed i think every way
possible it's like i had the book the
audiobook the movie and now the remake
and the movie the first one made a
number of changes that were just kind of
like movie changes that felt like i
don't know we gotta kind of tailor this
to american
hollywood audiences or something and so
like now that we're past
that hurdle like i kind of appreciate
the changes they seem like they're
making here and making something that i
don't know could be a bit more relevant
i don't know exactly how they're gonna
use the civil rights
you know time in america to complement
what's going on in this story but you
know if we're here to update it and
reimagine things
it seems like a fair way to go and and
yeah i think anne hathaway makes a great
grand high witch at least from the looks
of it
yeah yeah so i mean it's got the spirit
it didn't make me go oh god what are
they doing to this
you know now i'm just sitting here
hoping that they can maybe bridge the
gap because they did say also that they
wanted to maybe hew
a little closer to the book which i mean
you know depending on who you talk to
there's only one like gigantic
difference they
you know introduce that changes the
course of the movie makes the ending a
little happier
um but yeah you know i'm curious to see
what they come up with for sure and this
was an enticing look at that looks
beautiful
i think what a lot of people have really
been wanting is a hocus pocus
reunion or follow-up or soft reboot of
some kind
also in the works i know it's in the
works right now and this gives me the
vibe
kind of like that this version does yeah
youth accessible horror
and also you know you got like kind of
some matilda vibe there's a whole bunch
of different vibes that i feel like are
really
meshed into this oh yeah and that's even
a little bit of like charlie and the
chocolate factory kind of
that's all yeah yeah and i mean it's i'm
just going on movies you think i've read
a book john
no but that's funny it's cool that that
should do that because it speaks to the
power that roald dahl has
just in his source material alone to
have these things feel kind of a kin
in spirit somehow the thing i'm most
excited about is just to see how octavia
spencer and the young boy uh
interact because you know that's the
heart of that story and in the original
movie which i do enjoy i
mainly took away angelica houston and a
lot of the effects yeah
so i'm really excited to hopefully have
a very heartwarming you know
relationship between them to look
forward to
yeah yeah and it also kind of reminds me
of spiral
yeah definitely with chris chris rock in
there spiral he's going to be
investigating the witches that you know
affected his young boy that's how this
is going to go
in a reverse situation of the help this
is how she makes up for that movie that
she's not proud of
white guy you're the help that's right
well they have one of the black-ish the
blackish creator i think co-wrote this
as well yeah i think with del toro's
touch it'll be a fun
spooky adventure all right guys well are
you excited for fantastic beasts three
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell last but
not least
i'd like to give a patreon of the day
shout out to the wickedest
most creative magic inducing
witch in a positive way which i don't
mean that in a negative
connotation like a great witch like a
sexy alluring but not sexy in a way as
if i'm you know coming
on to you just you know it's just a
natural feature
you are a very intelligent creative and
i mainly admire you for your
personality and uh your strengths and
your mindset
all right just john can you just shout
out erica tuesday
erica okay you are the white witch of
our
channel you've got such magic but you
know how you harness it you harness it
for the good you're not trying to be
out here wiping all the kids out of the
world
you're trying to enrich their lives
trying to bring us
all messages that we can grapple with
but in a wonderfully magical animated
form
you are magic and that's why you're the
grand high witch of this channel
now take this choking curse off of greg
before this channel shuts down for good
please
he's going to turn me into a rat please
don't just gonna tell me it's all right
i know please
don't do that i can just talk to you in
your goodness
i'm sorry love you erica i hope you're
well
i admire you okay
hey that's that's good too and uh
you